hey guys I'm Lisa from the score eSports
the regular season of the 2017 EU LCS
spring split has finally wrapped up with
many great performances across various
teams we're counting down our picks for
the top 10 players from this regular
season coming in at number ten is
fanatics ad carry reckless
although fnatic haven't been excelling
this split reckless has carried his team
to the playoffs even though his team
isn't at the top of the leaderboard he
still maintained a 6.9 kDa ratio one of
the highest you know beside a book if it
is their John Seely so much doubted how
far he takes it down so I was looking to
get a little bit more cats the one
taking it our the puppy badgers they go
forward just disappear reckless though
all alone it does not matter grabbing
the ninth spot on our list is GTS
junglers trick with incredible farming
stats trick often finds himself way
ahead of his opponents during game being
part of a top-tier team trick has been
able to out farm and often outperform
his jungle matchups each week strikes
there's a detention though amazing gets
routed into place trick best the shield
gonna be able to pops it there's no
damage
iPhone does not hurt looking for the
shield boom trick gets the reply what a
way to die coming in 8th on our list is
mistresses ignore few supports provide
us much impact as ignore has he's
arguably become the best support in the
EU LCS largely due to his ability to
land clutch ultimate it's easy to see
that ignore has played an important role
on the team will get props dancing to
down the bottom Lane its ignore that
land the cacao is coming for supporters
leaps forward for first blood have a
look at the setup you actually got the
Riverwood from the side of giants and
whatsoever is coming down the river oh
really good old exhaust could be
splashes in advance lands the play gets
into a position where he's in front of
husband visitor she grabs the 7th spot
on our list visit chachi has not only
brought experienced the unicorns of love
but is incredible mechanic in the top
lane to being the glue the whole team
together his undeniable presence on the
risk earned him a spot honor lit him up
Oh Sophie oh my word oh toes got a run
for his life
it's no visitor she's got red buff big
shield from that Titans wrath but it
doesn't matter grabbing the sixth spot
is ace UK's nuclear after being imported
from the lck into EU nuclear has quickly
risen to the top of the EU ad carry
ranking while maintaining a 5.9 kDa
ratio he's also demonstrated his
mechanical ability by winning
game-changing teamfights in the Bobby
oxen nuclear always going to have to
blackout that and so as goes too far
nuclear gets a third kill H UK's iconic
jungler yankov comes in fits on our list
the first blood King has unleashed the
beast to split totally 134 kills and a
70 point one kill participation
percentage a standout jungler in many
matchups yankles has been a major factor
in h2k success Kranthi shield is he
McTavish yeah cuz what's the highlight
one is going to take him down Jordan cen
goes oh it was perfect
unicorns of love's jungler birthday
comes in fourth on our list maintaining
the highest kDa ratio in the EU LCS this
rookie has outperformed many other
junglers this splits being fairly new to
professional play he stepped up showing
he has huge potential in the LCS all fit
so that's he is flexing at the Barrett
looks like we had before us why I'm
gonna try to secure the bear Joe is that
cacao comes in at number three on our
list there was a lot of excitement
surrounding cacao introduction into the
LCS on misfit and he definitely lived up
to the hype known for being a god
unleashing he's led misfit into the EU
playoffs but with the presence of two
carries for another mentos know is that
from the voice by flash foretaste of
fears not enough to read but the slows
down the mentos kit counties to get in
range the cooldown look in a container
Barcelona's lockdown cacao to his own
tonight nights running a little low on
mana 200hp
can't cut offs I skip
- really good I'll play from cacao power
of evil comes in second on our list with
misfits having just been promoted from
challenger it was unclear whether they
do well to split however they've
exceeded all expectations mostly due to
their daring mid laner power of evil
maintaining a high KD ratio as well as
being at the top of the kill leaderboard
he's the mid laner many of his matchups
dear sister Connecticut misfire but
they're engaging also Carol power of
evil he just wants to 1v1 any kids it
earning first place on our list is G
Tuesday D Carey
ven-ven is one of the most consistent
players we've seen on top of being a key
reason why g2 has remained so dominant
he's also maintained a high KD a ratio
and has performed outstanding this
entire split depended going forward
exhaust drop isn't going to be enough as
the overstated welcome tom oh no the
charm hit he's knocked out spends on the
backline he's doing his best bang
impression wants to keep the bike going
ego through another one that is good for
g2 there you go those were our picks for
the top 10 players from the 2017 EU LCS
spring split do you agree or disagree
with our list let us know in the
comments below thanks for watching if
you want more great content be sure to
hit that subscribe button